you like that don't you
yeah
or gloria though huh she'll be fine
oh you have a little something oh i get
it this time
oh excuse me
oh the soup is ready i bring some for
gloria
i'm not crazy right
no she's into you
thank god you wandered down here when
you did you see how she keeps sliding
close to me it's like eating on a boat
it's so much worse than that it's
straight out of lethal ladies look what
i found in the trash
pictures of me and gloria and gloria's
head cut out she literally wants mom out
of the picture hold on amigo is she
infatuated with me yes understandable
unavoidable but would she actually do
something to her own what she just took
a bottle out of her purse and sprinkled
it into mom's soup okay that's enough
for this dumb tv show for you
we're talking about a perfectly
believable obsession you're trying to
make this into something that here manny
that's for me what about jay oh it's too
spicy for him i make another one just
like yours for your mother eat it while
it's hot okay
oh my god she wants me out of the
picture too
of course young woman meets a wealthy
older man who wants a kid in the way
that's the first airtight thing you said
today but she's not a murderer oh stella
no
oh that's nice she let me eat this just
clean it up
open your eyes jay she wants you all to
herself the red dress just like mom's
the toy she knew mom would trip on the
headless pictures she's crazy
you think i'm crazy
this is what i did with the pictures i
made this valentine for gloria
the dress i borrowed from gloria to go
with your pretty necklace
and the poison is wasca a spice i
brought from colombia
and there's stella with the toy which
she lives all over the house there's
been some misunderstanding here but it
would be so super if you just wouldn't
mention this to me please
flout as these two are they move like
cats i heard everything on the baby
monitor how can you say these things
about my sister i was just trying to be
nice jay
i would call a cab and wait at the
airport
now i know what your family really
thinks of me sonia wait i
i have been working on fixing my
relationship with sonia the whole week
and because you think you're a sex
machine you have ruined everything i'm
sorry i'll talk to her
sonia i'm an idiot
i jump to some crazy conclusions today i
mean i could say it's because of
valentine's or i don't know
me feeling a little neglected
but i know you could never kiss me yes
because you're my sister-in-law and uh
we hit it perfectly jay swung away we
waited long enough one night with me and
you'll forget all about her she doesn't
appreciate you i hear how you fight
that's just how we talk give into it jay
we both
oh no
how dare do you try to steal the life
that i stole from you let him go gloria
i love him
he's my husband and i love him
ladies ladies
[Music]
you